[Music]
on this Saturday night mourning the
death of a mounty the grief and the
growing memorial for the Fallen BC
officer and father killed in the line of
duty I'm just
sad someone went to work didn't come
home one year on it prays on people's
minds every time something forms in the
Gulf down the struggle to rebuild in
Porto Basque ahead of the anniversary of
hurricane
Fiona growing concerns about shrinking
glaciers and rivers in the Rockies so
this is actually worse than the worst
case scenario the fears and far-reaching
consequences of a devastating
drought a rare Cosmic gift it's almost
like you know a snapshot in time from
4.6 billion years ago the asteroid
sample returning to Earth and the
questions it could help us
answer global national with far Asser
reporting tonight through gcha good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin tonight with a BC community in
mourning over the killing of an RCMP
Constable gunned down in the line of
duty Ridge Meadows RCMP Constable Rick
O'Brien was honored with a somber
funeral procession last night as his
body was transported to abbottford BC
the 51-year-old officer was fatally shot
during an altercation while searching a
home in quum BC two other officers were
also injured a suspect was shot but
survived he was arrested and has now
been formally charged Julia Foy is
outside the RCMP station in Maple Ridge
BC where a memorial honoring obrien has
been growing Julia what's been the
community's reaction and how are they
remembering Constable
O'Brien NE through I'm here outside
Ridge Meadows RCMP where we've been
watching dozens of people stop by this
Memorial site bringing flowers letters
and momentos all to honor and remember
Constable Rick O'Brien who died in the
line of duty on Friday
afternoon now he was attending in a
neighboring community of kitam he was
issuing a search warrant with at least
two other members an altercation broke
out at a condo in kitum shots rang out
and unfortunately Constable Rick O'Brien
was killed at the scene all of his
service with the RCMP has been in Ridge
Meadows Detachment as a Frontline police
officer and in community policing within
months of starting he was involved in
the rescue of several victims as a
result of a home invasion including a
child and the subsequent arrest of the
suspects for his actions he received a
commodation from the CEO for bravery and
a provincial award according to McDonald
Ottawa born O'Brien had just celebrated
his seventh year of service with the
rich Meadows
RCMP today he's being remembered as a
father and husband who led by example
every day in our
Province men and women put on a uniform
to go out and to keep our
communities our people
safe sometimes they don't return home
today we heard from many people about
what he meant to them or what he did and
meant to the community just have to lose
a couple more police officers is not
right and it's it's hard breaking when
you think about it it was important to
be here because we love and respect uh
police officers and law enforcement and
we have a law enforcement family Daddy's
a police officer and my dad was and my
grandfather was a source has told global
news that the suspect that was taken
into custody after the condo shooting
remains in hospital but has been charged
with first-degree murder and attempted
murder two fellow officers who were also
injured in the shooting have since been
released from hospital and been reunited
with their families more information
about a public memorial for Constable
Rick O'Brien will be coming in the next
few days or weeks back to you Neu Julia
Foy in Maple Ridge BC thanks
Julia Constable O'Brien is the 10th
police officer killed in the past 12
months in May Ontario Police Sergeant
Eric Mueller died during a shooting in
March Quebec police Sergeant Moren bro
was killed in a stabbing that same month
Edmonton constables Brett Ryan and
Travis Jordan were both fatally shot
responding to a domestic dispute in
December 2022 Ontario Police Constable
Greg piala died after being shot in an
ambush in October 2022 Burnaby RCMP
Constable shayin Yang was fatally
stabbed responding to a welfare check
that same month South Simco police
constables Devon Northrup and Morgan
Russell were shot while responding to a
disturbance call and later died and last
September Toronto Constable Andrew Hong
was killed by a lone gunman during his
break to the mounting tension now
between Canada and India over prime
minister Justin Trudeau's explosive
allegation potentially linking that
country to the killing of Canadian sick
leader hardip sing ner India denies any
wrongdoing but there are questions about
how Canada's allies should respond to
the Diplomatic dispute Britney Rosen
reports this house belongs to the older
brother of hardip Singh ner niger's
uncle in India says the property seized
by India's top investigation agency
today as the six separatist murder
remains at the center of a diplomatic
route we are deeply concerned about the
allegations that prime minister Trudeau
has raised Canada's closest allies
including the US have publicly expressed
worry over tensions with India they've
also pressed for answers it would be
important that um India work with the
Canadians uh on this investigation but
not one of the five eyes intelligence
Alliance has accused Delhi for its
alleged connection to Niner's
assassination this despite reports one
of its members provided some level of
intelligence to Ottawa the Allies are in
a bind it's a it's a no win really for
for the US for the UK and for other
Western countries who supplied the
additional intelligence and what its
contents are remain unclear but one
expert says it was likely Washington
given reports that President Biden
raised the matter with the Indian prime
minister at the G20 Summit allies are
walking a tight rope between backing
Canada while not fracturing relations
with India India is the West's big bet
um in containing China a much needed
Ally for the West as a count counter
offensive to beijing's projection of
power India is quickly becoming a state
to be reckoned with with one of the
largest militaries and an economy on
track to become the third largest in the
world by 2030 neither country wants to
uh to to imperil the long-term future of
the relationship so I think that the the
hope is that in due course cooler Minds
will prevail it isn't yet clear what the
seizure of nar's brother's property in
India signals about delhi's intentions
will it conduct its own private investig
or concede and cooperate with the
Canadian government those questions
remain top of Mind in what appears to be
a diplomatic game of chicken between the
two countries Neu Britney Rosen in
Washington thanks Britney as the rift
between India and Canada deepens prime
minister Justin Trudeau now finds
himself in a diplomatic bind and a
battle with the world's largest
democracy prior to the death of hardip
Singh ner Trudeau was tting Canada's
indopacific strategy as a way to pull
economic Reliance away from China over
foreign interference our Ottawa bureau
chief Mercedes Stevenson spoke with
defense minister Bill Blair about how
this Feud with India jeopardizes the
Canadian government's economic
strategy one of the biggest commitments
your government has made on the defense
file is to the Indo Pacific strategy and
it seems like now you're in a bit of a
difficult situation with India and the
experts who were speaking to on this
show are saying they don't expect this
standoff to disappear quickly has this
jeopardized your government's ability to
proceed with that if you have India uh
basically very angry with Canada and
likely not looking to
cooperate well Mercedes just to be very
clear if if the intelligence that we've
received um is is proven to to be
accurate then then there's a very
significant concern that Canada will
have with respect to the violation of
our sovereignty and the murder of a of a
Canadian citizen on Canadian soil and at
the same time I also want to acknowledge
the importance of the indopacific
strategy we've been working very hard
over the past several years and and most
recently um in in building trade
agreements in in the region and through
the the Canadian Armed Forces we have
been increasing our presence and Patrols
in the region and and so the Endo
Pacific region including our
relationship with India is important to
us but also standing up for the
international rules-based order and
ensuring that we defend our sovereignty
and our citizens this is our first
priority and so you know we understand
that this is this can be and and and has
proven to be a challenging um issue with
respect to our relationship with with
India but at the same time we have a
responsibility to defend defend the law
to defend our citizens and at the same
time make sure that we conduct a
thorough investigation and gets the
truth tropical storm opilia has made
landfall along the east coast of the
United States lashing communities with
strong winds and dangerous storm
surges
the governors of North Carolina Virginia
and Maryland each declared a state of
emergency Friday closing schools and
cancelling weekend events the fierce
storm hit North Carolina's Coastline
early this morning with near hurricane
strength winds clocking 110 kilm per
hour opilia is expected to weaken as it
turns North before taking a turn to the
Northeast
tomorrow tomorrow marks one year since
the small town of Porto Basque in New
Finland and Labrador was devastated by
post-tropical storm Fiona the extreme
weather event whipped up Fierce winds
and huge storm surges causing 100 homes
to crumble one woman was killed the
Insurance Bureau of Canada says Fiona
was the most costly storm in Atlantic
Canada's history and the 10th overall in
Canada and a year on as Mike Dray
reports many of those who lost
everything are being told they can't
rebuild
the rocky Shoreline of Porta Basque
looks Serene today park benches and
gravel Mark the edge of Water Street
what a difference a year makes oh my we
got to go same spot different video post
tropical storm Fiona didn't give
residents much time to react as the 15 M
High storm surge tore through homes
almost dragging Brian Osman out to sea I
thought I was gu and me brother come out
he thought I was
Guy before Fiona PTO Basque residents
hadn't worried too much about hurricanes
which most often hit the eastern part of
the province if at all those beliefs
have certainly changed it prays on
people's minds every time something
forms in the Gulf down south uh down
Barbados or the Grenadines um you know
people pay a lot more attention to it
now because they know the impact
is it's possible that it's going to it's
going to come back at an announcement
this week regarding the ongoing issue of
recovery funds MP gy Hutchings spoke of
the new reality so folks look we know
the oceans are rising the water
temperature are warmer in the oceans
hurricanes are stronger and they're more
deadly than we've seen before and when
it became clear insurance companies were
going to refuse to pay damages citing
the absence of surge protection The
Province was left with a difficult
choice to make parts of portabas
determined to be in Fiona's Impact Zone
would be declared off limits so homes
that were destroyed won't be rebuilt and
some that survived will be torn down
roughly 150 in total owners will be
compensated but they don't have a choice
in the matter you know some people are
very relieved some people are very upset
some people are terribly confused I know
someone who's in a very low-lying
area um their house wasn't impacted and
they've got to go however three or four
houses down um and that's house that was
impacted
remains clearly much is left to figure
out for this small town on the
southwestern tip of Newland the scars
left from Fiona still freshen their
minds Mike drle Global
News cracking down on migrant
trafficking coming up the Italian Prime
Minister's call to wage a global war
against
Smugglers the migrant crisis gripping
Europe is only getting worse today the
pope criticized countries for their lack
of urgency and action speaking at a
conference in southern France Pope
Francis condemned what he says is
belligerent nationalism and indifference
the pontiff called for greater tolerance
for migrants crossing the sea and that
countries should find more ways to help
them otherwise they risk turning the
Mediterranean into a sea of death the
Pope's remarks come as Italy's Prime
Minister calls for help with the number
of undocumented mented migrants arriving
there doubling this year Redmond Shannon
reports in the space of one week this
month around 11,000 migrants arrived in
Italy's southernmost island of lampedusa
that's almost twice its population were
in the sea for almost 30 hours most were
quickly sent for processing in
Sicily but many Island residents have
had enough Italian Prime Minister
Georgia Malone visited with European
commission president Ursula verion
migration is a European Challenge and it
needs a European answer and solution
fion has issued an EU plan much of it
focused on preventing arrivals and
sending migrants
back this week Maloney told the UN she
wants help to Target migration root
causes and to stop people Smugglers last
year she was elected on a pledge to
reduce migration we're seeing a little
bit of I would say radicalization of of
this approach to close Borders or at
least to attempt to in July both leaders
signed the latest deal to prevent
departures this time with Tunisia but it
does not appear to have worked so far
and some migrants found themselves
stranded in no man's land between
Tunisia and Libya in the EU as ever its
27 governments find it difficult to
agree on any solution I really think
that the political discourse is toxic
right now in Europe Italian migration
analyst Kelly patillo says properly
implementing safe and legal Pathways for
economic migrants would help make
immigration more functional as would
better cooperation on settling refugees
something the US Canada and Italy met
about in New York this week when we look
at the actual uh facts and the and the
statistic and compare them with other
countries outside of Europe like turkey
we are not really talking about huge
numbers nonetheless
178,000 have risked their lives crossing
the Mediterranean Sea so far this year
and as long as global inequality remains
that's unlikely to stop Redmond Channon
Global News
London ahead and historic glacial melt
the impacts of a devastating drought in
western Canada tonight there's concern
over rapidly melting glaciers and rivers
being severely impacted by the warmer
than normal conditions and lack of
precipitation in the mountains as Jamie
dah reports Alberta's Rockies are
bearing the
brunt Dryland training in preparation of
his 50th season in the sport he helped
birth but the landscape has shifted
greatly since legendary alpinist Jim
elzinga first swung his axe into a
frozen waterfall the glaciers that that
I visited are just about no longer there
and these glaciers and these ice faces
are are disappearing they're just
becoming big pieces of rock the Rockies
are at the epicenter of a devastating
drought that has had far-reaching
consequences across western Canada
glacial melt this summer has been
historic the iconic Athabasca Glacier
had a downward melt of 9 MERS this year
the biggest loss ever recorded and
there's more well this year we didn't
get the rains and uh but we had the
reduced snow pack in the early melt and
so this is actually worse than the worst
case scenario that we had been
suggesting for the end of the century as
a result Palm Roy says crucial waterways
like the bo River in Alberta are
experiencing the lowest stream flows
ever measured and many are starting to
feel it this always has water in it
throughout the season and then you can
see now it's like be we're worried for
sure fishing guides in Canmore have not
been able to get into places they
normally would the river is so low
that there's spots on the River where it
comes very multi- braided channels that
you ground out it's disappointing Pomroy
is calling the depletion of critical
water sources a National Emergency that
needs urgent attention we need to manage
our water differently in Canada and we
don't have time we we have to do this
very very quickly it will take
record-breaking snow and rainfalls to
recover from the current deficit
according to Pal Pomroy and
unfortunately we are in an
year that typically brings warmer and
drier conditions to this area for Jim
elzinga the toughest climb May lie ahead
inspiring environmental stewardship
before it's too late Jamie doll Global
News
Canmore longdistance delivery next
preparations as NASA's first asteroid
sample makes its way to
Earth this is a big weekend for the
Canadian space agent and their
colleagues at Nasa the Osiris Rex
spacecraft is on its way home and it's
bringing samples from the surface of an
asteroid here's Mike
Armstrong this is a dry run for the big
event to come the team at NASA's Johnson
Space Center in Texas rehearsing what
they'll do when they get their hands
albeit gloved on a longdistance delivery
we're all very excited about that Kim
Tate is part of the Canadian delegation
headed down to Texas for what is a NASA
first the capsule set to Tumble to Earth
Sunday will be carrying material from an
asteroid likely about 4.6 billion years
old for Canada's contribution to the
$800 million Mission Canadian scientists
will get 4% of the material to bring
home and study the one thing I can
guarantee is that we will find something
we didn't expect and lift off of Osiris
Rex the spacecraft was launched in 2016
its destination benu a carbon Rich
asteroid mostly covered in rocks and
boulders and about the size of the Cen
tower now the mission wasn't just to
take some pictures it touched down on
the surface in 2020 to collect samples
one of Canada's contributions was an
ultimeter an instrument that helped with
the landing you know we didn't know the
gravity field as well as we needed to do
to understand how the spacecraft would
react around benu so our our data really
helped that the journey home was more
than 1.9 billion kilomet NASA won't know
exactly how much material the capsule's
carrying until scientists open it next
week but they believe there's about 250
g about the same weight as a cell phone
we'll be looking for uh carbon bearing
minerals we'll be looking for Organics
amino acids because all of these things
are the sort of materials that were
delivered to Earth that helped life
flourish here now if things go according
to plan Osiris Rex will release its
sample return capsule early Sunday
morning but its job won't be over while
scientists will start analyzing what
it's brought back it'll head out again
in 2029 it's supposed to catch up to and
study another asteroid apus sort of as
an encore Mike Armstrong Global
News and that is global national for
this Saturday night I'm nugara from the
Osiris Rex to a Tyrannosaurus Rex we'll
leave you tonight with a sculpture fit
for a prehistoric King tonight's your
Canada is this giant 177,000 lb metal
T-Rex statue in Penticton BC
commissioned for a vacation rental
property sculptor Kevin Stone worked on
it for two years the dinosaur statue
finally roared into its new home on
Thursday thanks for
watching